[Music]
within the Zelda chronology we find many
recurring features spanning across
multiple titles in the franchise one of
which being the sages they seem to
operate on a similar basis as link zelda
and even Ganon with elements of the
Divine reincarnation ancestry and
spirituality however the rules bound to
the sages differ between games and are
never consistent with Lincoln Zelda
things are pretty straightforward at
least since the release of Skyward Sword
that is since this is the first game to
finally explain how it all works as a
quick recap zelda has the blood of the
goddess highly out running through her
veins which has passed on from
generation to generation and because of
tradition within the royal family each
female born into this bloodline shall be
named zelda
hence the recurring name so each
iteration of zelda we see in the series
is in some way related by blood to the
very first one from Skyward Sword who
was the first to take on the mortal form
of the goddess if this bloodline were to
be broken
aka Zelda dies before she can produce
offspring the mortal reincarnation of
highly I would in all likelihood cease
to exist the main purpose of this divine
inheritance comes in the form of the
power to seal away evil which in most
cases is crucial to defeat Ganon the
existence of the many links across the
history of the series is tied to the
spirit of the hero what this spirit is
exactly is a bit hazy but it seems to be
some sort of spiritual essence that
endures over time and awakens within
certain individuals in a certain time
period when their courage is needed the
spirit also seems to be connected in
some way to the Triforce of courage some
are born with it or maybe it's mabeline
and others obtain it as their quest
unfolds as opposed to Zelda this
continuation of this line of Heroes is
not dependent on bloodline in fact we
only have one confirmed case of two
heroes being related by blood without a
shadow of a doubt that being the hero of
time and the hero of Twilight I'm
inclined to believe that the hero of
winds and the link from Spirit Tracks
are also related since well just look at
the similarities but anyway a hero
infused with this spirit can come from
different backgrounds and their age can
vary as well the only restrictions we've
seen so far
is that in all cases the subject is male
and of highly in descent even the
existence of Ganon is pretty
straightforward as he is simply an
incarnation of the hatred from the demon
king demise also from Skyward Sword who
upon his defeat uttered a curse that
would forever plagued Hyrule with an
eternal struggle between the Trinity of
power wisdom and courage aka the hero
the princess and an incarnation of this
evil Ganon's continued appearance across
the series is simply a physical
manifestation of this curse with the
sages however it becomes real confusing
real quick so before we get into the
events of the era of the wild I want to
go over some of the stuff we know about
the sages so far how their inclusion
changed and in some cases even retcon by
Nintendo first off let's start with the
ancient sages also known as the original
sages these individuals are said to be
the very first of their kind and ages
ago built the temple of time to protect
the entrance to the Sacred Realm
additionally they've also been
attributed to having some sort of
involvement in crafting the master sword
but as we have seen in Skyward Sword
this narrative seems to have changed
since the forging of the master sword by
Lincoln Phi is literally one of the main
goals in the story and there are no
sages involved though we do find a
reference to them in the seal temple
even the original goddess sword which
serves as the basis for the Master Sword
is set to have been crafted by a goddess
hylia now it could be that instead of
forging it herself she instructed the
sages to do it but to me it seems like
Nintendo simply altered the backstory or
maybe forgot about the original
narrative of this group of ancient sages
there's only one of which we know the
identity that being rauru who first
shows up in ocarina of time to lead the
newly awakened sages and guide link
along his quest both in his human form
as well as his owl form and yes cavora
gerbera is confirmed to be the
reincarnation of Raoul however strange
that may seem the six beings we see in
Twilight Princess although they look
completely different are set to be the
ancient sages the very same who built
the original temple of time preceding
Skyward Sword by that definition one of
them is Raoul however the other five are
not necessarily the same sages we see in
ocarina of time well they
in our but also not really we'll get
back to that later traditionally the
main narrative has been that we have six
ages of water fire shadow light forest
and spirit plus a seven sage which is
none other than Princess Zelda herself
who as mentioned before is the more to
incarnation of heylia so seven ethereal
beings goddess heylia and the six
ancient sages in the original version of
a Link to the Past there is mention of
seven Wiseman however this was later
retconned by Nintendo and changed to
seven sages on the Gameboy advanced for
the American version that is because
apparently they were always called seven
sages in Japanese but was mistranslated
two wise men in the English version it
is widely accepted that this change
pretty much proves that the seven sages
mentioned in the backstory to link to
the past are indeed the very same sages
from ocarina of time since it seems to
describe exactly that which took place
during this era where the sages seal
away Ganon inside the Sacred Realm for
the very first time and thus
transforming it into the dark world we
see in a Link to the Past though in
ocarina of time they call it the evil
realm now during the events of a Link to
the Past we have six maidens plus Zelda
who are descendants of the sages from
ocarina of time and inherited the
magical abilities of their ancestors
through the use of his alter ego agony
Ganon sends these maidens into the dark
world in an attempt to escape his prison
and return to the world of light however
this never comes to pass as link defeats
him before he can make it happen so in
that case we are still on the right
track here right six maidens
aka sages plus Princess Zelda but of
course we have a problem because we can
never have anything be straightforward
in Zelda lore now can we other games in
the series have featured more sages or
additional sages with new elements we've
never seen before the Wind Waker only
features two that being the sage of
earth and wind now it is suspected that
there was originally supposed to be more
of them at the very least three since
some dungeons were scrapped to meet a
deadline a link between worlds feature
seven sages however the seven one isn't
Princess Zelda this time they are all
set to be descendants of the original
seven sages but that makes no sense by
that logic one of them has to be the
offspring of zelda from a Link to the
Past the most likely candidates based on
race would be Gally
the son of the local blacksmith a
swallow who is sorry less apprentice or
Cerys the daughter of the priest at the
sanctuary so after a link left Hyrule to
venture to : there's elder hit it off
with the local blacksmith at that time
but the blacksmith in the link to the
past were Dwarfs right we also don't
know who as far as related to besides
the royal princes wouldn't marry some
mere peasant it's more likely that she
would marry someone close to the royal
family which oh my god that sneaky
bastard but even then if zelda had more
than one kid one being the new
incarnation of heylia did the other kid
only inherit her sage powers why would
her power split into two different
people and when at this seventh or
technically 8th sage come from if there
was originally only seven entities to
make matters even more confusing both
sahaj Rolla and Agena the two old men
found in a Link to the Past are also
descendants of the original seven sages
I'm getting a migraine in the older
games on the NES the numbers also varied
the guy who gives you the sword at the
beginning of the game sage the other two
guys that give you the silver and magic
sword sages this guy from zelda 2 sage
in Phantom Hourglass we can find a
graveyard with six sages who are laid to
rest here but this game takes place in
the realm of the ocean King how can the
six stages from Hyrule be buried here or
are these six other sages from a
different world altogether it's a mess
now we're gonna get into breath the wall
- don't worry it's coming but before we
do I think it would be wise if we try to
at least make a little bit more sense
out of this whole situation and try to
determine what even a sage is exactly
the definition of the word sage is that
of a person who possesses a profound
wisdom often through experience in the
Zelda series this seems to span further
than just wisdom and also part of
something divine and as we've clearly
seen so far this aspect is never
consistent their numbers change their
purpose their race gender age etc for
this theory I had to ask help from one
of the Masters of Zelda lore mr. H m'kay
because frankly I really needed some
intel on this one so consider this part
to be a collab without actually
collaborating it is speculated that a
sage can take on two different
appearances an ethereal spear
and a physical form in order to take in
a physical form they need to be
reincarnated into a physical body one
game I haven't touched upon yet spirit
tracks features the locum oh by the way
spoilers for the ending of Spirit Tracks
incoming this group despite their
different name are basically the sages
of new Hyrule which is not the same
place as the original Hyrule mind you as
by this point in time that Kingdom now
lies at the bottom of the Great Sea they
might even be the very same incarnations
of the ancient sages there's a total of
seven of them at the end and the colours
seems to match that of the sages of
Ocarina of Time one of them called Baron
initially didn't get granted the power
of a sage because his heart was not pure
and he had a lust for power frustrated
by this rejection he turns to the dark
side and together with Chancellor Cole
he conspires to free the demon king
maladies from his prison
long story short burn redeems himself at
the end but he dies in the final
confrontation with maladies after
maladies is defeated the locomotor
turned back to the heavens but before
they do one of them and Jean who burn
was an apprentice off states that locum
oh never really die but rather they get
reborn eventually without a memory of
their past lives this might explain why
the number of sages and even some of
their elements differ from game to game
it's never stated that the group of
ancient sages consists of only six or
seven for all we know there could be
many more of them
however only the ones that are relevant
to the situation plaguing Hyrule are
sent back to earth to fulfill their
purpose it also explains why they keep
appearing in different forms races and
genders
they are reincarnated without any memory
of their past lives but when the time
comes and their skills are needed they
awaken hence why the sages from ocarina
of time for instance didn't know about
their destiny as a sage until the time
came to take action in all probability
the ones we see in Twilight Princess are
the true forms of these beings without a
physical body sages are in that regard
immortal however their physical forms
are not they eventually die just like
any other being and reincarnate years
later which is why some people can be
descendants of one of the sages but not
be one themselves they are only related
to the physical being that the sage
inhabited at that
in many ways this is very similar to the
spirit of the hero they don't need to be
related by blood they can be but it's
not a requirement just as a new hero can
always awaken when the time comes
so does a sage as for their purpose it
depends in ocarina of time the main
purpose was to aid link in his quest and
ultimately seal Ganon inside the Sacred
Realm in Twilight Princess they tried to
execute him once and for all but after
failing to do so sealed him into the
Twilight Realm when even this wasn't
enough the only thing they had left was
to instruct the hero on his quest to
strike Ganondorf down and succeed where
they had failed well for a while anyway
we'll get to it in the Wind Waker
sealing away Ganondorf wasn't even an
option anymore and in this case their
goal was to offer prayers to restore the
master swords power to repel evil after
the original two sages were assassinated
by Ganondorf in other games the sages
are guarding the Triforce of courage it
really does seem that whatever divine
task is required at a time of peril they
will act upon that which needs to be
done and the nature of this task can
differ which finally brings us to breath
the wild and its upcoming sequel in the
battle against calamity Ganon we had the
five champions which are by no means the
same thing as a sage they do have their
own unique powers and abilities but as
we know from past games having access to
magic isn't restricted to divine beings
alone as we see many others using it as
well the champions are simply skilled
individuals who with the exception of
link himself are tasked to pilot the
divine beasts to subdue Ganon enough so
that Lincoln delivered the decisive blow
with the sword of Evil's Bane and Zelda
use her divine power to seal it away
however as we all know now calamity
Ganon was just a puppet howl Zelda is
doing is basically send a piece of
malice into the void
the real threat lies somewhere deep
underground we didn't see any
involvement of the sages in this
decisive battle nor are they mentioned
in the battle of 10,000 years ago but
this isn't to say that the sages weren't
referenced in the era of the wild to
sages from Ocarina of Time route oh and
nabooru
are mentioned by name the for divine
beasts are named after sages from
different games varma dough after medley
of vajradhara after darunia furuta
after Udo and Vanna Boris after nabooru
then we have the seven heroin statues
which are confirmed to be a memorial to
the seven sages and an additional eight
statue in the Gerudo Highlands the Lord
of the mountain found on Satori mountain
is said to be the reincarnation of a
sage that died on the lands it now
protects and then there's one other
reference big one however this one is
not found in the base game but rather in
DLC pack 1 more specifically the trial
of the sword the whole purpose of the
trial is to unlock the massive swords
true potential by battling your way
through different stages of combat
challenges at the very end we find a
massive sword in a pedestal with seven
Sheikh among surrounding it six of them
strike the same pose as the six ages
from ocarina of time did when they
sealed away Ganon now does this confirm
that these monks are the incarnations of
the sages in the era of the wild
unfortunately no this could of course
just be a reference or an easter egg
it is quite striking though that the
monks seemed to offer prayers to power
up the master sword just like they did
in the Wind Waker this ritual seems to
lack the element of music though unless
the monks were having a sing-along
right before link walked in the hay at
the same time Nintendo is known to
change certain rituals so it doesn't
disprove this theory either the monks do
disappear after link obtains the fully
powered Master Sword so if these were in
fact the incarnations of the seven sages
that would mean that they are now gone
if you ask me I'm not so sure of the
sages will even have to make a return in
the sequel it is made clear that zelda
sealing power has greatly diminished
after the endgame in the wild but maybe
sealing away Ganondorf again will not be
the final goal here but rather similar
to Twilight Princess straight-up killing
him instead we know that sealing him
away doesn't really do much other than
delay his inevitable return and as has
been mentioned by other channels like
Commonwealth realm perhaps the only way
to finally defeat Ganondorf once and for
all is to break the
curse of demise how this can be achieved
is beyond me at this point but there is
a very good chance that the sages are no
longer needed like they were in past
games so there you go
a 15 minute video for a relatively short
and concise answer to be honest this
video was supposed to be a short and
simple one I could have simply dive
straight into the breath awhile to stuff
but first of all there wasn't really
enough to talk or speculate about and
second I wanted to give more contexts
show you guys how confusing the aspect
of the sages has been throughout the
series and how this all might tie
together with the events of the next
game I hope you enjoyed the video and
thanks again for all the support
speaking of support we have a new
patreon today
say hello to Adam Hughes thanks a lot
for joining man it really means a lot
next week is gonna be a pretty crazy and
ambitious video which I won't spoil for
now except that it's about breath the
world big shock I know I hope to see you
then this is dawn signing off and have a
good one